hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the hospital play you got
nothing else to say oh oh
search trip search drugs oh my never
ending quest
I need more thank you very much okay so
the thing about this game or at least
what I've been able to deduce from the
game is wow this is trippy controls okay
if it feels like I'm control oh no
someone closed the door okay if it seems
like I'm controlling like a drunkard wow
these are not intuitive but oh hey whoa
whoa Oh God okay then sorry um
whoa Mike what's it like hi what do I do
oh hi well then I may not want to
lollygag even though most of what I want
to do pretty much all the time is
lollygag hey stop that now okay so
there's a weird thumpy foo where where I
don't see him oh god I see him oh I
don't see him anymore I am stuck what am
i stuck on the wall thank you oh god man
that is just bonkers this game looks
pretty good but goddamn it controls
bonkers and supposedly I'm only gonna be
able to see them through the little item
down here and why do I need drugs oh why
am I so addicted is that an acciden have
please oh no
Oh oh hi oh yeah you seem to be dead huh
a bad case of death poisoning I'd say
caused by an explosion of death from the
pelvic domino region and then yeah some
further death lacerations oh hi sir
I apologize if you're mourning the loss
of your friend over here uh okay cool
all righty then that was weird what the
hell is happening there's really
interesting design I must say like I
gotta admit this is actually pretty Oh
Oh God Oh what was that Oh
oh my goodness oh they got me Oh what
the hell happened it doesn't it does it
doesn't seem to be all 100% there I will
readily admit I am NOT fully all God
stop that oh you stop that oh you stop
dan dan dan dan okay so he goes away so
appears here it seems that he only
appears every so often and then goes
away after he's done doing his little
drum solo drum solo you know if I could
talk properly oh there's the same place
that was before okay this is where he
killed me is that drugs is that the
d'oeuvres I need is that that sweet
black tar heroin that I want in my veins
is it I have no idea I did
haha whoa back up oh hey hey buddy how
you doing okay I was about to do another
drum solo to interpret what he was doing
now I don't exactly know where I'm
supposed to be going or what I'm
supposed to be doing it doesn't besides
find ergs which you know supposedly
thought it might have been a little bit
easier to find ergs okay then he just
wanted to let me know he was still
chasing after me what a nice guy I don't
think I'm gonna be able to go up here
dan dan dan okay then what am I supposed
to do burn burn burn burn okay so I
guess I could go up here the other side
was a stairwell as far as I could see
but hi
okay then goodbye I don't know if I
should be worried about you
god damnit is he up here don't do that
stop that oh I see how this is
I haven't faced a jump-scare like that
in years of course I haven't really been
playing a lot of indie horror games for
a while now whoa whoa hey how's it going
there buddy two of them
what I have no idea what's going on
really interesting mechanic but they
could do without the cheap jump-scare I
know that for a fact
ah
oh don't just one just wondered um he's
getting closer
oh my god I feel so stir stad he's gonna
kill me I'm gonna get stuck on the door
and then he's gonna kill me
oh boy Oh Dirk's yeah I got my sweet
black tar heroin now be able to face the
troubles of my everyday life hey whoa
what the poker thank you sir so uh ma
where am I gonna find one of these
things are exiting thingies but I just
got to go down to the back way I came
probably okey-dokey then
wow that music is dramatic I sure am
scared oh hello
how convenient for me oh god I thought I
was falling I guess I'm okay then
oh hi oh god damn it love [ __ ] that oh
come on are you kidding me here
oh what a bunch of malarkey how oh is
that [ __ ] what was I supposed to be
able to do put a bunch of a wholeness
and the stupid jump scares I haven't
faced stupid jump suit yeah yeah go away
screw your face hey yeah I got breathing
problems fear me huh oh yeah the gym
skier I thought we'd moved past this as
a society but I guess when you got a
hospital full of people whoa
very desperately searching for drugs
okay then bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
when you got a hospital full of people
looking for Dirks and I don't know why
this guy's so desperate that he needs
drugs in a random abandoned Hospital but
you know he still has enough together
that he can buy this weird camera
looking thing oh oh I'm playing this so
you guys don't have to that's the main
thing I was actually impressed I was
actually impressed because the ambience
was seem good and you know it seems like
an interesting mechanic having to look
through the camera was actually pretty
cool Hey yeah look at me yeah and so you
know it's kind of disappointing to know
that it's actually very poorly like put
together not that the individual pieces
of it not that the individual pieces
themselves aren't bad but I mean come on
come on
come on hello all right thank you anyway
Derrick's oh my god delicious 9-ball
cocaine I don't know what they call it
out I don't know my drugs
so far so good I guess I'm just gonna be
enter my way back home the only other
problem that I have with it though is
that it's really annoying to have to
watch the small screen when I'm already
looking at it through a small computer
screen so it kind of just blim 'its the
game view to this tiny little screen
that I'm holding in my hands which you
know kind of interrupts everything
alright let's see if I can do this
without dying because [ __ ] you man
that's so stupid
oh wait I can't man I want to say nice
things about you but you make it really
hard on me I wanna be a fair reviewer
but sometimes I have to be mean oh god
damn whoa whoa almost got me on that one
slim e Jim you ain't gonna get past me
though
yeah the stealth skills of something
that's stealthy try this again okay the
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna wait see I just looked up for the
first time in forever did my did my
character just like scoot past an entire
layer of floor okay I'm looking I see
nothing I see nothing I see nothing
I see nothing how do I get past him well
how am I
so stupid there's no way there's nowhere
to go this is been a fruitless task it's
been useless oh come on
there's been no reason there's been
nowhere to go the whole time okay maybe
there is maybe you guys found my dough
well I have no idea so that was the
hospital
I can only imagine that this is a demo
but there's a lot of interesting
concepts here like I would have a few
things to say about the screen it's an
interesting concept to be able to see
things that aren't always there but
forcing the player to look at the tiny
screen the whole time kind of takes away
from the entire environment because I
can't see any details and I'm always
looking at it it's a nice design but the
it's a nice choice but the design of it
forces the player to only look at that
it'd be nice to have it where you could
put it up there's been a few games that
are like that where you put it up close
to the face and it shows everything or
maybe like something quick that you just
turn on and you can see things that
aren't there so there's some potential
here just refine it so uh in other news
I still got the cat shirt unless you
haven't seen the video with the catcher
or the dog shirt then I'm selling cat
vs. dog shirts you can buy them through
the link in the description below after
we see who wins and I decide what prize
- a lot - the winner I have no idea
really yet Matt put in prize I've got
ten million of cash money Wow $10,000 is
gonna be donated to the Best Friends
Animal Society because chica and Lego
now Ryan's new dog has brought a lot of
joy in my life and made this house a lot
happier so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out those links to
the shirts in the description below
they're only gonna be available a
limited time so check them out while you
can
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
alik without those